التحقيق الخاص بك مهم لنا جميعًا
في العالم ، وأود أن أبدأ
بفكرة انتشار الفيروس في
البداية من خلال الأطعمة المجمدة التي تفعل
كما اقترح نيك المطابقة مع رواية
قدمتها الحكومة الصينية والتي
اعترض عليها على نطاق واسع
علماء آخرون على المستوى الشخصي
لأي شخص يستمع
إلى القلق ، هل يمكنك مساعدتنا في
فهم سبب اعتقادك
أنه قد يكون قد حدث على هذا النحو
جيدًا ، فنحن نتحدث عن شيء
مختلف تمامًا الآن
عما تعرفه مجموعة من
الأسماك المجمدة من مكان آخر  في
العالم نتحدث عن
أصول sarsko v2 ، تفشي الطمع في
أحد الأسواق
في ووهان ، حيث كان المركز المحتمل
لانتشار هذا الفاشية مبكرًا وما
نراه على الرغم من ذلك عندما نزور هذا السوق
هو مكان يبيع  الكثير من المنتجات المجمدة
ليس فقط الأشياء النموذجية التي نشتريها
من السوبر ماركت ولكن أيضًا
المنتجات الحيوانية المجمدة من مزارع الحيوانات
في جنوب شرق آسيا وداخل الصين
وهناك حقًا ستريكي  قطعة من
الدليل الذي تم ذكره اليوم
في المؤتمر الصحفي أنه في تلك
المنتجات تم تضمين
لحوم الحياة البرية وجثث الحيوانات التي نعرف
أنها معرضة لفيروسات كورونا
وأيضًا أن سلاسل التوريد تأتي من
أماكن في الصين حيث نعرف
فيروس كورونا الثاني.  تعد الفيروسات ذات الصلة
بعبارة أخرى
رابطًا مباشرًا من أصول الخفافيش
المحتملة لهذا الماضي والتي
يعتقد معظم العلماء أنها صحيحة
في سوق ووهان الآن قام العلماء في
الصين باختبار تلك الجثث
وكانت سلبية ،
وهذا أمر جيد ولكننا لا نعرف
ماذا كان هناك أيضًا
لا نعرف حقًا ما إذا كانت هناك
حيوانات حية هناك ، لذلك لا يوجد دليل على
ذلك ولكننا لا
نعرف ولا نعرف عدد هذه
الحيوانات التي كانت جزءًا من هذا
السوق المجمد أو حتى أنواع اللحوم الأخرى
حتى تعرف  بالنسبة للكثيرين منا في الفريق
، كان ذلك دليلًا واضحًا على ما قد
يكون قد حدث ، وكان
أحد المسارات التي اعتقدنا أنها أكثر
احتمالية من الآخرين بالتأكيد ،
دعني أتحدث  من الواضح حول
هذا الأمر ، فهو أحد تلك المسارات
التي قد يكون من المرجح أن
تقولها وهذا اتفاق أه الذي قمت به
كفريق ولكنني أجد صعوبة في
فهم دليل محدد على أنه
يتعين عليك دعم هذا الخلاف سيدي باحترام
جيد  يأتي الدليل
من العمل الذي كان يقوم به تشان والذي كان
العلماء الصينيون
يفعلونه منذ اليوم الأول من تفشي المرض ، لذا في
حوالي شهر يناير ،
دخل العلماء الأوائل من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض الصيني إلى
السوق وبدأوا في
مسح السوق الذي نظروا فيه إلى مياه الصرف الصحي التي
نظروا إليها  الأكشاك التي باعوا فيها الطعام
، نظروا إلى الحجارة حيث
كان الناس إيجابيين لفيروس كورونا
، أمضوا حوالي شهر هناك في
مسح
أكثر من 900 عينة جمعت دراسة
متعمقة حقًا
ومعظم منتجات الحيوانات
قد اختفت ولكن كان هناك بعضها
وما زال
هناك  إذا كانت هناك
حيوانات حية في السوق ، فإننا نعتقد أن
الحيوانات المائية بشكل أساسي ولكننا لا نعرف أن
هناك شائعات
عن  الثدييات الحية في هذا السوق ، ولكن ما
كان مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا هو اكتشاف
جثث الحيوانات الثدييات في الواقع
، وهي نوع من
الحيوانات التي تؤكل على نطاق واسع في جميع أنحاء
جنوب شرق آسيا والتي نعلم أن لديها
القدرة على الإصابة بفيروس كورونا
في المنتجات المجمدة التي تم اختبارها  سلبي
ولكن القليل منها
يخبرك أنه من المحتمل أن يكون هناك
المزيد في هذا السوق في
وقت
مبكر وهذا احتمال لطريقة
يمكن أن ينتقل بها الفيروس إلى
هناك ، هناك مساران آخران
نظرنا إلى أحدهما كان من الممكن
إحضاره  من قبل
أشخاص من جزء آخر من
ووهان وسمعت أن بعضًا من
الأم بحلول الوقت الذي عُرفت فيه الحالات المبكرة في
ديسمبر ،
بدا لعلماء الأوبئة في
الفريق أن هذا الفيروس كان
ينتشر بالفعل على نطاق واسع في
المجتمع وهناك دليل على ذلك
يُصاب بعض الأشخاص بالعدوى التي لم تكن
مرتبطة بالسوق ، لذا
كان من الممكن أن يدخلها شخص ما ،
ثم هناك أخيرًا هذه الفرضية التي نوقشت على نطاق واسع
أن سلسلة التبريد للأطعمة المجمدة من
أماكن أخرى مثل الخارج كان من الممكن أن
تجلبها الآن ، وهذا
في رأيي أقل احتمالًا ، لكن من
الممكن أن
أبقيناها هناك كإمكانية للقيام
بمزيد من العمل ،
فمن السهل جدًا الخروج
والبدء في الاختبار  أولئك الذين يرون
ما هو احتمال هذا المسار
ولكن من وجهة
نظري وأنا مهتم جدًا بالحيوان
المرتبط بهذه الأوبئة ،
كان هناك احتمال واضح لوجود
ارتباط حيواني من
الحيوانات التي نعرف أنها عرضة لدخول
هذا السوق
أم لا ،  مشكلة الطعام المجمد
ما أفهمه مما
قلته للتو هو أنه لا يوجد
أه هذا ليس دليلًا على أنك
كفريق قد وجدت هذا أه هذا
عمل كان يقوم به طفل صيني
أنك قد استمعت إليه
وأخذت على عاتقه و و
و وهكذا فهذا
ما فعلته الصين على
عكس
العمل الذي استخلصه ووجد دليلًا
على كل شيء على
ما يرام وماذا عن القضية الأولى  كما
فهمت ، فقط اشرح فقط
ما تعلمته
جيدًا ، كان لدينا فريق من علماء الأوبئة
في المجموعة
يعملون مع فريق جيد حقًا من
الصين ، أعني أن هذا جهد مشترك
تعلم أنهم يخرجون ويجمعون كل هذه
البيانات عبر  في العام الماضي
ونحن نجلس ونحللها معًا ،
نراجع الدراسات ثم
يخرجون ويجمعون المزيد من المعلومات
ويبحثون حقًا عن
مجموعاتك
التي تعرف أن معدل الوفيات الزائد الذي كان من الممكن
أن يقترح أن يتم
تغطيته كان موجودًا في وقت سابق كثيرًا في
ووهان أو
حتى  مقاطعة حول غوهان و أو كانت
هناك
أنماط غير عادية لأمراض الجهاز التنفسي
التي تم التقاطها في العيادات المحلية
والتي تشير إلى حدوث طفرات في
الفاشيات من المهم جدًا القيام بذلك
لأن
ما يخبرنا به هو أن هذا الشيء
ينتشر في المجتمع
لفترة أطول بكثير مما نحن عليه  فكرت وكان من
الممكن أن تأتي من مكان
آخر وأعتقد أنها اكتشاف مهم للغاية
ولكن فريق epi
مقتنع تمامًا بعدم
وجود مجموعات واضحة من
من حالات تفشي هذا النوع من تلك
البيانات قبل شهر كانون الأول (ديسمبر)
ويبدو أنه لم يكن
هناك انتشار كبير لهذا المرض
قبل كانون الأول (ديسمبر) ، ربما
كان هناك عدد قليل من الحالات المتفرقة هنا وهناك
لا نعلم أننا بحاجة إلى مزيد من البحث
ولكن هذا مهم  يبدو حقًا أن
هذا الحدث في ووهان
حدث هناك ، حدث مبكرًا في
أوائل
ديسمبر ، تم التقاطه في الواقع بسرعة إلى حد ما ،
لقد كان حدثًا متفجرًا
مرتبطًا بالأسواق حول ووهان بيتر وما حولها ،
هل لدينا مريض صفر
ليس بعد ولكن أم أنت  نعلم أننا في كثير من الأحيان لا نتحمل
أبدًا المريض صفر
وقد يكون المريض صفر شخصًا مات
أو شخصًا مسنًا مات بسبب
الالتهاب الرئوي وهو أمر شائع ،
فقد يكون شخصًا
لا يعرف أبدًا أنه مصاب.
يمكن أن يكون بدون أعراض ، يمكن أن
يكون لديك أعراض خفيفة
يصاب كل شخص بالبرد في الشتاء ،
يمكن أن يكون شخصًا لم يعرف أبدًا أنه
مصاب بالمرض
، من الصعب جدًا الوصول إلى المريض صفر
ولكن هناك الكثير  يمكنك أن تتعلم من خلال
النظر إلى هذا
التتبع للأحداث العنقودية وهذا ما
تبحث عنه أنت تبحث عن
مجموعات صغيرة من الفاشيات التي انتقلت
إلى العيادة لأنها كانت شديدة
وكانت أعراضها مثل فيروس كورونا
الذي لم يحدث.  لا أرى ذلك
في البيانات
قبل ديسمبر نتيجة مهمة للغاية